[Musik]
und eben zwei wochen haben und mit dem
chorus infiziert
[Musik]
das ist mit das schrecklichste baby
berkshires tun
zum glück wie vor hat erwähnt aktuellen
statistik schwangerschaftswochen was
bedeutet dass es allzu lang wird oder
bis mittel sind zeigen vor wochen
geklagt weil die sport in der
schwangerschaft ist nicht nur spontan
dazu entschied also wirklich spontan und
es ist sehr real
[Musik]
und es geschah dann der virusinfektion
ist dagegen ein bisschen leichter zur
und gäste sich kritische wort sexy und
allgemeines unwohlsein hüttig es
wahnsinnig wahnsinnig stark besonders
abnahme
[Musik]
spaghetti zu machen und
sich einfach mit rein gar nicht angaben
eigentlich deine fehler verschmerzen
es ist jetzt prüfen lockdown amys leben
sich durch doch geändert
ein normaler strom laufen und denke
spital aber dass gott mir arbeite mit
dem velo quasi schaut einfach die
sicherste methode das alles gut und
müssen da steckt als arzt ist daniel
eberle in bereitschaft das zürcher
unispital wappnet sich mit dem märz für
den ansturm von schwerkranken corona
patienten aber jetzt in der krise
schaffe so david mann aus schwerte und
da im kurgarten durch das unispital hat
die riesige verbundes leitung von der
sonderaktion so fonds eher an strände
auf der urologie alles aber auch machen
können damit auch die räumlichkeiten
quasi ausliegen intensivstation genug
gebaut werden
die ruhe im unispital ist ist momentan
wir sind bereit fast tatsächliche
ausführung noch und mathematisch mister
kollege für den notfall medizin und
intensivmedizin schafe gestaffelt und
das urologie habe auch bereits und
helfen wo machen aber als mir mit
momentan ohne dach dies mache
doch einfach nutzbare die assault on ist
der kranich ob das ist kein spiel mit
dem woche also wenn sie jetzt groß ist
dann muss man es einfach und schnell
wasser bevor das merke ich habe gott
steht nach der klasse dass das mit dem
geruchssinn also doch am schluss wurde
er krank und das ist zwar nicht
ausgeschlossen
spitzel hoffnung das ist alles wie der
verlauf der krise bereit das wenig
passiere aktuell also mitte gebaut und
unter kohl ohne dass durch für einen
verdienten sieg und psychisch partner
sondern gegner der größe dreyfus gemacht
dass man sein konzept oder
glaube ist natürlich dass die spitze im
bund
[Musik]
camila und louis auf dem weg zurück in
die schweiz
unplanmäßig die korona krise bedeutete
das jähe ende ihre skandinavien reisen
sie befanden sich in norwegen auf das
land den lockdown anordnet und dicht
macht keine flügel chaotische verbindung
in ihrer not kaufen die beiden ein auto
drauf und ihre gäste wichtige mitteilung
der örtlichen behörde die gefahrenabwehr
ist aufgrund des corona virus unter
druck bitte beenden sie ihren urlaub
gemüse wir dass man jetzt am besten weg
und fordern ufo tormann sind es
eigentlich immer schräg wie sie die
gemälde bekannter lautenden botschaften
und es ist eigentlich genau am schluss
noch keine krisensituation im überblick
dort verantwortete sie wo sie eignen
auch im fünften gang gefahren
daher kaufen wir zwischen den menschen
eine praktische tun bekommen
das
sandra kießling rettet lebensmittel vor
dem müll bei gastro betriebe aufgrund
der korona krise geschlossen sind
bleiben händler und lieferanten auf
ihrer ware sitzen
schwierige zeiten auch für gemüsebauern
das ist schön aber das ist leider aus im
moment wird das privileg dass ich von
meiner mama riedstadt im abfall landen
spinat und crouch stil in sandra
kießlings laden zu günstigeren preisen
das ist so
und das ist schon sehr gut weil es ist
dass wir endlich die bewohner das hilft
einfach überhaupt haben einfach unser
und sich zwar lautet ob nicht das bringt
anke huber
bewusst wurde was reaktion mit telefon
dass sie buttons mit technisch für das
ohne machen
die lachen
[Musik]
rowling hat sich für die kränkung
wieso noch gegen die homeschooling
macher im hintergrund mit der
homeschooling abfangen pariert sv
eskaliert also es ist nicht möglich sie
zwei kinder gebaut und ist einfach nur
zerstören
[Musik]
louis und camilla nach drei tagen
nonstop im auto noch drei tage bis zum
das heißt
die schulter ich mache
moralische morgen informieren und
-analyse mobiler maschine wird bringt
genau das hört sich die lieferservice
prozent
das gehört zu unterstützen aber viele
machen das handy corona restore und doch
das virus hat einfluss auf die situation
werden der eltern in den spitälern und
praxen dürfen väter zwar bei der geburt
nicht aber beim wochenbett und auch
nicht an den voruntersuchungen dabei
sein
ein buch allein das ist für sportrechte
krise kann diesbezüglich werde eine
ganze fremdbestimmtheit wo du darfst ja
ich bekomme in grenzen
eine ausgeburt also die mich ein
spielangebot dass das so läuft also wenn
sie gerade sich seine jacke mit ob denn
das sind 1600 morde sowie jana tourismus
hat sich spd pro familie abstand halten
da bin jetzt so verpflichtete jetzt
gespannt und ruhezeiten
[Musik]
natürlich ein lautes das boot wenig zeit
der sturm wird sie wie strang und wie
gut die ihr die empathie gekaute
handhabe das hätte sich auch
unglaubwürdig sie also jetzt dieses
video machte von christoph bellgardt das
baby noch den motor sie bitte einen
autokauf die hat mir so leid es ist so
eine liebe familie wo es ist so zusammen
hauttyp i han so die regler kaufte also
das hat mir das nie belastet
seit mir emotional sehr genau steht ja
die aktuelle verbote elektiven griff es
gibt aber schon wo man module für wie
zum beispiel alligator sind de greeff
otomo relativ schnell wachsen und damit
man vorwärts machen dass sich der
patient nachher wirklich ein nachteil
ja ich habe schon eine weile mit ihnen
reden wir operationen müssen oder wie
ich habe mal weekender trat nur gut für
tumorbiologie und ich mache mir sorgen
um sie momentan das ist nieder bis wo
man jetzt nur von mäßigem druck für mich
sagte die zusätzliche belastung
fast alle unterschätzt moniz zeige ich
hab mein dass wir das was wir ab dem
sinnvoll beim profi wer mit dem umgang
mir sind viele patienten mobile
beruhigen
es sind viel telefonnummer mache es ihn
viel eigene stimme zum teil sind die
agra fertig zum teil erneuert und zu
erläutern
wer gern gelacht so was mache den
nachrang landrat kießlings man dennis
beim homeschooling mit den kindern
aufgrund der doppelbelastung haben die
eltern arbeit und familie nun klar
aufgeteilt
[Musik]
mittlerweile ist er schon da war gesetzt
nach zehn tagen seltsames gefühl und die
radiologische diesen abstand hatte das
ist ganz klar
aber der ist einfach immer so einfach
links in einer hollywood film
[Musik]
auf ihre rückreise in die heimat
durchqueren camilla und louis schweden
während die schweiz still steht geht
hier das öffentliche leben weiter wie
das abläuft haben das vorzug dieses land
frag ich mich halt mich lieb ich weiß
gar nicht so genau was im moment trägt
sich an russland halten aber ich würde
mich einfach mal zwei wochen verschoben
zu haben sind und dann und dann wieder
zu mir halt ruhe und nehmen und dafür
die nomad mitglieder so dass es wurde
komisch sie uns nach darf aber nicht nur
von hier aus korea
doch dafür brauche ich wenn ich da bin
die deutsche startet sarah 14 uhr kamen
weitere mini schweiz die nicht witziger
saison rettig putzer
und einfach com mit der haare rosa ist
bekommt das ist etwas was mich jeden tag
auskommen
nach der santa cruz zu hoch
guckt und sich noch siebter bestatter
benny hochuli hat einen offiziellen
auftrag die herstellung von spezial
werden auf vorrat holzkiste um holzkiste
stapelt sich abholbereit in der garage
so dass man natürlich oder vorkommen ist
das unnatürlich aufstockt
[Gelächter]
so wie z
wo die maßnahme die zeit vor ihrer
abwesenheit hatte nicht darstellen
davon ist sie überzeugt das problem ist
dass jetzt niemand tracht verlasse
gagfah lassen
ja sicher april das ist viel flotter
geht und es ist der internet las bringt
im moment eine viel anders tür und und
das ist eine möglichkeit sich bemerkbar
zu machen ist geboten
troisdorf
große sprünge sehen
und
was hier die zur seite schaute mich
die zahl der todesopfer infolge einer
carola infektion in der schweiz stieg
ebenfalls von 378 auf 432 laut simon ist
kathi und das macht sie handel per
facetime haben wir kontakt zu leuten und
gespräch und heute gehört das tv
webseite
zudem habe immerhin weiß es nicht
[Musik]
das muss kontrolliert werden konnte
wenig später sitzen nach sechstägiger
reise kommen camilla und louis an der
schweizer grenze an
noch ist unklar ob sie den grenzübergang
mit dem in norwegen gekauften auto ohne
weiteres passieren dürfen
wir sind auch die spots sind jetzt zwei
tag die heimat der christen amerikaner
oder wie sie bliebe da bin ich sehr froh
ist jetzt sogar die ganze macht
[Musik]
neben tools